à Blois une vraie chaîne de solidarité
s'est mise en place grâce à des
bénévoles qui travaillent à la
Croix-Rouge leur mission vont de la
distribution alimentaire jusqu'au je
suis désolé Camille mais on fait pas de
distribution alimentaire à la
Croix-Rouge ah d'accord donc
voilà vestimentaire
et de ce fait là on voit qu'une façade
qui est pas directement
d'abord il y a notre inscription qui est
là haut
si tu voulais bien plutôt filmer l'autre
façade elle est pas au soleil ce coup-ci
mais parce que est-ce que tu vois bien
l'entrée où on va dépasser la porte
ouverte là et ça c'est l'accueil
ouais bah oui je suis désolé action ah
bah donc du coup je refais la fin du
lancement donner c'est mieux que jeter
et ça permet d'économiser les ressources
de la planète et aussi de se relooker et
ben je t'emmène
[Musique]
tu veux bien filmer nos paquets on
appelle ça avec colis les personnes qui
vont venir les chercher c'est des
personnes en grandes difficultés qui ont
été repérés par un travailleur social
donc ça marche
non parce que je te voyais bouger du
coup nos bénévoles nous fourmis derrière
constitue le colis et la personne vient
chercher examine si ça lui convient et
puis voilà donc on va on va continuer
vers la vestiboutique ce qui est
intéressant à voir c'est que la
mannequin mini sur la porte alors là
c'est magnifique allez vas-y Camille
mets-moi de ta main sur la porte je vais
le faire à ta place j'étais trop rapide
là
parce que quelque part tu vas rentrer
dans dans le cœur de notre action
humanitaire d'accord plus doucement quoi
et surtout plus doucement et puis
surtout pas de flou c'est parti action
vas-y doucement mais oui
allez viens Camille voilà notre boutique
il est simple c'est de proposer un
maximum de vêtements qu'on nous a donné
alors on va avoir des vêtements déjà
portés et des vêtements tout à fait
neufs notre objectif il est tout simple
c'est de faire de l'action sociale tu me
paraît un peu loin là pour non c'est pas
possible que tu viennes plutôt par ici
là si tu veux te mettre ici là dans le
milieu là vous voyez très bien là
impeccable ouais bah oui là tu as une
bonne tête qu'est-ce que ça donne le son
et si vous parlez là qu'est-ce que ça
donne alors Didier je suis vraiment ravi
d'être là
et donc le perchiste un peu derrière
l'image s'il te plaît si c'est possible
action vestiboutique numéro 2 numéro 2
c'est parti alors oui alors on a une
mission Lucien on a une mission on doit
prouver que on peut se saper s'habiller
se taper comme jamais maître Gims pour
faire c'est pour toi
à la vessie boutique et pour pas cher et
pour pas cher en plus comment tu me
saperais
on va trouver une chemise
blazer et un pantalon un peu loose aussi
caméléon
[Applaudissements]
tu le prends sous tous ses angles
et ben on y va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]